what's going on everybody and welcome to
a JavaScript basics tutorial series what
we're not going to be doing in this
tutorial series is covering concept
after concept with toy example after toy
example because by the end of it you'll
have forgotten 75% of it and I just
don't see the point so we're going to be
doing is actually building something the
entire time and then just kind of
learning along the way so I'll do my
best to explain everything but if I make
a mistake or I didn't explain something
clearly enough feel free to comment
below also if you've got nothing to say
you might still want to check them out
because chances are I've made some
mistakes and someone might have
corrected me so I am by no means a
JavaScript expert I have been
professionally copying and pasting
JavaScript for quite a few years now and
I'm really just trying to learn it more
so that's part of why I'm doing the
video so yeah feel free to tell me why
I'm stupid and or learn some JavaScript
with me so with that let's go ahead and
get started it's actually pretty simple
to program with JavaScript you really
just need two things you need an editor
and you need a browser I hope you
haven't a hope you have a browser by now
and if you don't have an editor I'm
gonna be using an editor called sublime
text and if you want to use that awesome
if you want to use some other different
editor awesome just understand no matter
what editor you choose there will be
hordes of people to tell you you've made
the wrong choice and that their editor
is better for reasons XYZ personally I
just like really simple editors but
different people have different desires
with their editors so try a bunch use
whatever you like with that let's get
into it so the first thing I'm gonna do
is just open terminal run sublime text
and I'm gonna save this as AAS tutorial
dot HTML and I actually want to say that
to my desktop awesome so for now we're
just gonna throw the JavaScript into a
really simple HTML document eventually
you're gonna separate these things out
and we'll probably end up doing that in
this tutorial but right now it's so
simple we're just gonna put it on the
same page if you don't know HTML welcome
to an HTML tutorial these are opening
tags these are closing tags you can tell
it because it's got a slash so that's
our HTML and our HTML as you might guess
goes in between zags so then we're gonna
have
some body tags this is where the content
of your web page goes so content here
now in sublime I just have a quick
little shortcut that I can hit and it
opens it in a browser if you want to set
up your sublime text that exact way
check the link in the description for
the text-based version of this tutorial
I put the instructions there do take
note there are other browsers though
that do this exact same thing
and some of them you might even think do
it better like some of them will run
this like little server that every time
you save it updates the code and does
fancy stuff so feel free check them all
out I get it your editor is better than
mine I'm fine so so anyway so the
content goes there but we're not doing
HTML and so we're doing JavaScript so
we're actually the content is just gonna
be a couple of script tags now if you're
in school you might have an instructor
that really wants you to put text or
type equals text JavaScript not
necessary anymore with html5 which is
what everybody's using by now so don't
worry about it but just know sometimes
people might think you should put that
in there so I'm not gonna do it so just
take note that I'm not doing it but
that's a thing so in here's where your
JavaScript goes the we don't know
anything about JavaScript so no matter
what I throw at you you're gonna be
slightly confused but there's a few
quite a few built-in functions so and
just built-in things if you just type
built in JavaScript
what is the mdn or something like that
there's just this you can see this huge
list so let's try built in JavaScript MD
in right so check this out these are all
your built-in objects it's a huge
freaking list these are things that are
just there all the time so things like
math and date stuff and all that they're
just there and you can use them so
anyways one of the things that's there
is alert it is everybody's honestly
everybody just loves it when you have
alerts on your webpage I know
alert is maybe my favorite thing to ever
run into hey why are you leaving so for
example here's just a really quick alert
let's check it out
it's just a like a
pop-up notification basically so a lot
of times you try to leave a website you
might see something like this sometimes
it's useful if it's like if you have a
website like a blog or you know maybe an
email site or something where if you
leave you're literally gonna lose a
thing that you've been working on so you
might have missed clicked or something
and so you might have a little pop-up
that's like hey are you sure but
otherwise you can just throw it at
people who are trying to bounce off your
site and people will just love it so so
anyway alert awesome you can also use
javascript to write directly to you like
as HTML so for example we can use
document dot right now this is like a
little challenging you see this all the
time in an intro tutorials so I guess I
feel ok throwing it in
but document is an object right is a
method and these parentheses here encase
parameters so you could just point to
the method but you can actually run the
method with parentheses so you sometimes
you might see methods that are just
empty parentheses because there's no
need for parameters in this case it does
take a parameter and it's what you
actually want to write so we're gonna
pass a string parameter and it's a
string because it has quotations and so
we can just say hey they're right so we
can document right now document is an
object and it's in reference to the
actual document object itself the actual
thing the person is seeing and the
browser basically so let's go ahead and
run that real quick and we see hey there
so it's just been written there now this
can actually be pure HTML so we can
actually throw like some strong tags
around this so that should bold it
strong run that again and we get nice
bold hey there so pretty cool also in
JavaScript you kind of want to end all
your lines with semicolons I'm gonna
forget them all the time but they should
be there anyway like I said I'm a noob
I'm also mainly a Python programmer so
yeah we don't have semicolons anyway ok
cool so we can document right we've also
seen the alert the other thing that's
kind of neat is you have consul so you
can console dot law
and then you can put a string thing here
thing here of note we can save that run
that in a browser
and usually I want to say it was an f12
yeah we can come over to the console and
we can see thing here of note and also a
little notification that we didn't
specify the the character set that's
okay I'm not going to worry about that
for now anybody who's using a browser
that can't figure it out
I don't want using my sites so for now
maybe later I'll reference that for sure
but anyways for now I'm not worried so
thing here if note it just logs to
console so generally if you want to do
like debugging you'll use the console
for this so another thing you can
console dot log you can thing here of
known you can log warned and error and
I'll just do all three normally I would
change the string but I don't feel like
wasting the time on that so come on over
here so thing here of note so it's like
nice yellow warning I can scroll in a
little bit but hopefully you can see
that actually I can't make that any
bigger I can make the webpage bigger but
I can't really make this bigger sorry
guys but you should be able to see that
and then thing here of no and then
usually you can come here and you can
figure out where that's coming from
exactly in the code just by like
clicking on it so later you might have
code that has actual debugging and then
you could go and see exactly where
something failed but enough of that what
we actually want to do is build towards
a thing and that's a game in the browser
so the first thing we have to understand
is how to actually use JavaScript to
manipulate an existing thing so one
example that I think is really simple is
like an input so if you had an input ID
I'm gonna say the ideas mod me and okay
I'm gonna try to camelcase everything
but I'm just not used to doing that but
that's a standard in JavaScript anyway
mod me id input ID mod me and then we
can say type equals text and then we
could put a value
here and we could just say starting okay
so we could run this and what we get is
a little input feel and it says starting
but we could change that as a user to
like whatever we want but we can also
change that with JavaScript so you can
change it based on clicks mouse
movements time elapsed or you can just
immediately change it so for now we're
just going to immediately change it and
we're going to say document dot get
element by ID and again we're
referencing the you know document object
so we're referencing this like HTML
stuff the stuff the browser sing and
then we're gonna get that element from
the browser with the ID of mod meat so
I'm just gonna pass that as a string and
then we're just going to change the
value so one way we can do that is just
dot value and we can just say equals
something else and don't forget your
final semicolon there and now let's go
ahead and run that and we see that
actually it's already been changed like
instantly because the script ran and
boom it got changed so so that's how you
could modify a certain property in here
but some of the other cool things that
you can do like for example is you might
have for example let's say a paragraph
tag and in here we've got yet again some
starting text now it doesn't have to be
a paragraph tag this could be literally
any tag in existence and but we're gonna
say ID equals we'll do the mod me again
and now I have starting text now if we
change that value let's just go ahead
and run that real quick we can see
nothing changed right because value
isn't the thing we're actually trying to
change like with there's really no
that's not gonna actually change the
text we actually were kind of hoping
that we could change the text so instead
what we would say is dot inner HTML now
that means exactly what it says you're
gonna actually change the HTML between
here so it could be something else you
could actually throw in more HTML
paragraph tags don't have to be
paragraph tags it could actually be a
div tag for that matter and you could
actually be passing more div tags and
many many paragraph tags so anyway let's
just check that out so now it actually
gets changed to something else so that's
how you can start modifying the stuff
that's in there
but instead what we actually want to
work with to make a game is a canvas
object and that's exactly what it sounds
like it's a place where we can actually
draw - so let's do it really simple
drawing and then I'm going to close out
this tutorial we'll pick up with the
next one so the first thing that we're
gonna do here is we're just going to say
canvas and we're going to say id equals
my canvas and then what we need to do is
specify the width that will be 200
pixels we'll specify the height also as
200 pixels and then we're gonna say
these style equals and then we're going
to say the border colon is one pixel it
is going to be solid and its color will
be hashtag zero zero zero for black so
so yeah so if any this doesn't make
sense like that was pretty much I guess
this is just some simple styling and
then these are just some properties of
this canvas super basic hopefully you
understand that if you don't again you
you can definitely go and look for like
some sort of HTML tutorial or something
you honestly should be able to learn all
this stuff in like 20 minutes or
something but also feel free to leave
comment below I just don't want to spend
too long on HTML stuff because that's
not really what this tutorial is ok so
we have a lovely canvas I'm gonna clear
out our script now and let's just check
out our canvas sure enough nice very
nice box nice clean canvas and we'll
draw to it because I feel like that
would be dirty of me to just leave you
guys with a nice empty canvas so now
historically javascript has always
referenced things with you know
variables but first I want to talk about
why do we even want to use variables and
then I'm gonna talk about things that
have changed
so first of all why might we want to use
variables well to draw to the canvas let
me show you what's required so - first
we need to access the canvas so we're
gonna just gonna use document dot get
element by ID if you use just mine that
would autocomplete okay so anyway I'm
sure there is there's got to be most
editors probably would Auto
plead that it's a good point also stop
that okay so we're gonna get my canvas
so that's how we're going to okay now
we've referenced now we've referenced my
canvas and now the next thing is I guess
that was my phone I don't know what that
sounds like cool anyway I live in a high
tornado area and so I have a alert app
that tells me when there's tornadoes so
kind need to finish the URL so document
dot get element I'm gonna be fine okay
so this is how we reference the canvas
now what we want to do is we actually
want to draw to the canvas now to do
that we have to actually reference the
canvases the context of the canvas so
actually we want to say dot get content
context I'm gonna type without a few
times and we're going to say 2d and
there's other context you could do a
WebGL and stuff you can get really fancy
but for now she's gonna be a simple 2d
object just to XY and that's that's just
to reference the context now what we
wanted to do is the first thing would be
we want to begin a path and that just
kind of starts fresh starts or reach
starts a drawing path okay so that's
just to start the path then the next
thing we're going to do right would be
to we would we'd begin the path then we
would move to and then we would draw and
all this stuff anyway that would be
really messy plus we got a ton of
repetition here every time we're just
trying to reference basically up to the
context so instead we might we would we
would use things called variables so you
might save our canvas equals I shouldn't
have done that but anyway I shouldn't
deleted that stuff document type get
element by ID oh actually it's my canvas
and then you would have var context
equals canvas dot get contact
so now we can reference both the canvas
in the context of that canvas but very
our var isn't really the most up-to-date
way to do this so actually there's var
let and Const and chances are like most
of time you should just default to Const
and then I would use let for when that
variable might actually change but it
can be kind of confusing but a constant
is just the assignment never actually
changes so it's not that the thing that
it's assigned to never changes it's the
assignment so canvas is canvas always
going to reference the document get
element by ID my canvas
yeah the canvas might change but this
this this actual you know this is our
nice assignment operator if this pointer
is always going to be to this thing then
rather than being a variable or let what
we actually want to call this is a
constant it's not changing the thing
itself can change but the actual the the
assignment won't change so like later we
can't say canvas equals to that we can't
do that okay so but with a variable or
let we could reassign the value but
we're not actually going to be doing
that in either of these cases so both of
these should be just constant so that's
how we're going to reference the canvas
in the context now let's actually draw
to this bad boy so first we're going to
say a context dot begin path and again
this either this either starts or
restarts a path then what we want to say
is context dot move to and then we'll
just say 1010 now what's happened is you
at begin path you've picked up your
pencil right it's off of the paper it's
off the canvas let's say and now you've
moved to these coordinates but you're
not drawing anything yet then so now
you're kind of at that coordinate you're
holding your mouse above the the paper
at that and then we're gonna say context
line two
and then we're gonna say 50:25 now you
might think you've moved the pencil at
this point but if we check it out you
haven't what gives
well actually you haven't moved the
pencil all you did was actually look you
just kind of looked to the 50:25 you
haven't done anything yet and so what
you need to do is context dot stroke now
you've done it and now we can run that
and oh my gosh we are artists beautiful
so so yeah so I'm gonna stop here we've
covered a lot of things we've covered
objects and methods and variables let
constant referencing elements by ID and
probably a bunch of other stuff I can't
think of all the top of my head but
we've covered a lot of stuff
thanks to my recent channel members
thank you guys very much for your
support if you want to support the
channel you can click that beautiful
blue button below the video that says
chewing we've got drak adducts back
after a month ssandsk are a brand new
member Dickson Craig back after a month
I've in for two months on its third
month digi err and uma Compaq for
another month thank you guys so much for
your support I love doing what I do and
you guys are making it possible so thank
you so much so in the next video what
we're gonna do is continue drawing on to
the canvas and kind of start moving
towards drawing something of substance
we've got a few more little things to
talk about specific to the canvas and
then we can start getting into more
interesting things like functions and
loops and stuff like that so stay tuned
if you got questions comments concerns
you think I did something wrong stupid I
could do it better feel free to leave
them below if you're curious about the
things I did wrong stupid or could do
better check the comments down below
otherwise that's it for now I'll see you
guys in the next video